haha
oh my God perfect
new house is right on the water come on
dog you know how we do GT would lime
we're not open until noon it is noon
it's 11 57. now what time is it 11 56.
[Applause]
good Lord you need to fire her I can't
fire her she has a disability what no I
don't you don't no that's the reason why
I heard you
I'm an Uber driver and I don't have a
car
what up
his parents said if I quote date their
son they'd give me a Buick Regal you
won't even rent your house up but now
you're going to rent out your badge you
have a roadrunner tattoo covering your
entire back I don't think you should
tell anybody what to do with their body
nope
I'm going to teach you how to have fun
am I allowed to be here I can't be
scared of everything your whole life
Maddie marker your little
disappearing act that was the best thing
that ever happened to me congratulations
is her vagina dishwasher safe she's a
real person what part of Russia did they
ship her from
she's Russian no
you need to learn how to party have you
seen Percy Percy Percy Percy
doesn't anyone anymore
[Music]
oh my god did you him I like your
house a lot it's cozy ooh we should have
some music
dance party
[Music]
you want to switch
yeah this is good
are you
[Music]